a net starts off this hour in Tampa
Florida hi Annette how are you I'm good
thank you Dave thank you for taking my
call sure what's up when you talk about
the four categories of mutual funds
aggressive growth growth and income is
it okay to have multiple funds in each
category or is it just one fund per
category oh definitely multiples if you
want to I mean I wouldn't have ten
dollars in each and have twenty funds
that drive you nuts but if you've got a
pile of money you don't want to have it
all in just four funds if you got two
million dollars I wouldn't want you
having a half-million dollars in each
fund okay so it's okay to mix it up
absolutely
yeah I know more than one fund in each
category okay yeah but I mean the thing
is just don't over complicate your life
there's not a huge gain by being in
different funds because a lot of those
like take for instance our growth and
income mutual fund and you look at a
different growth in income mutual fund
if you look at the stocks they hold
there's a lot of overlap right correct
they look a lot alike so you don't gain
a lot of power of diversification by
having more than one but I like having
more than one I you know there's another
thing you want to push against to try to
balance if you're buying loaded funds
like I primarily do especially in
retirement is you get break points once
you get above certain amounts invested
within one fund family one brand of
funds okay and so if you can stay with
your first million or so in one or two
brands of funds you can get some savings
on your commission break points oh okay
okay but other than that I mean yes it's
a good idea to have more than one fund
in each category but I wouldn't want to
complicate my life and I exaggerate with
a dollar but I'm even even $10,000 you
know if you had a million dollars
invested and and you never had more than
ten thousand dollars in one fund you'd
have a whole bunch of paperwork flying
around all the time and really didn't
accomplish a lot by being in that many
different funds but it's certainly okay
to have more than one fund and recommend
that it once you start getting some
zeros on those things as far as the
amounts invested
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you are not a victim you're not
a victim of big corporations you're not
a victim of Wall Street you're not a
victim of capitalism you're not a victim
of wealth inequality you're not a victim
of racism you're not a victim